hey guys today we are lucky to have mr.
Nicolas Winding Ruffin in office to talk
about his new Amazon series too old to
die young wonderful title by the way
instant hook we got to see just so they
know where I'm coming from we got to see
episodes 4 & 5 which is what you showed
a can and I overheard you talking to
Steve outside a little bit to sort of
perceive it like like the younger
generation where we could drop in an
episode 4 & 5 see if we like it started
from the beginning kind of roll with it
that way was there aside from that did
you just feel like these two episodes
together had a sort of filmic story you
could take to a film festival and give
to critics well yes because the whole
movie you know I who do movies so I
decided to make a long movie on
streaming and then I would chop it up in
different rhythms meaning that episodes
would be different lengths just like a
book I thought well it's 13 hours long
so just showing episode 1 it's not
really an introduction to the world and
I thought when when you go buy books you
know you take them down from the shelf
when you browse through it you very
rarely read the first page you go into
the middle and assess and then you
decide if you want to buy it or not so I
thought well let me show the heart of
the show so I went straight to the
middle and that means that after 2 hours
that you have seen there's still 11
hours to go on both ends of the spectrum
so to me that was just a more kind of
authentic way to present to you the
world of by NWR through to old to die
young and at the same time it was a
great puzzlement which of course is
always fun to talk about because
everyone always searches for and
answer yeah of course I find it
particularly intriguing because kind of
contrary to that didn't you guys
actually film in chronological order I
shoot everything at you in
chronologically order so it was like one
giant canvas like one operatic scenario
of just painting everyday but you guys
you guys filmed for an incredibly long
time right I shot for ten months yeah
that's that is a long shoots everyday
how does I mean is there a difference
between doing a filming something
chronologically for you know a few weeks
to a few months to then 10 months almost
a whole year of taking a story from
front to back absolutely because when I
do my films they have roughly between
five to six weeks shooting schedules
which you know it's a little more
adaptable you know to kind of sanely
yeah get through but for ten months you
know you go a little cuckoo once in a
while and then you still wake up and
it's the same thing it's a bit like
being in Groundhog you know it's like
was that movie where he reached up and
the same song begins again after like
six months you go to set and you're like
whoa I was just here a month ago and you
know you get a little disoriented but at
the same time it's incredibly
intoxicating because you're just working
you're painting every day yeah and
that's when you're alive so it was also
incredibly thrilling how do you when
you're at that point where you're going
a little cuckoo and you're like let's
say month seven and it's it's a lot how
do you make yourself get up the next day
and go through the next Groundhog Day
well TV like everything in in cinema and
so forth it's very also practically
driven you just have to get up yeah it
was hard as probably on my family
because I wasn't around a lot and that
of course is a huge guilt trip so there
was a lot of pain in that at the same
time you know the idea that you wake up
and it's like
just the disoriented was almost became
part of the create a process like you
lose yourself in this world because of
chronologically I could decide every day
how it would evolve and it was going
through your self analysis completely
and utterly it's like it was like
therapy from ten months that's well that
also sounds intense I'm curious so you
you co-wrote this with Edie Brubaker who
is of course a legendary comic writer
and did some writing on Westworld and
it's just a brilliant writer but I'm
curious why his his tone his style was
something you wanted to be a part of
this world well I I had been friends
with it at you know prior and I had
hired him on a another project that I
owned called maniac cop and he's written
script for and it's now being developed
for serial opportunities and I loved
working with that on Maniac Cop and so
when I had the idea for tools and
tae-young knowing the two giant beasts
he would become I thought it was a great
way for us to do some things where I
would even direct it and then we started
working on it and of course his his
story sensibilities his natural ideas of
how to come up with interesting
narratives and characters we were a
great match you know but we were missing
a link and I went to Alejandro
Jodorowsky in Paris to have at our
reading on what I needed to do and the
of course it became very clear what we
needed was a woman so I brought in a
writer called Hal across who it had
worked with another project so they were
very very friendly very very close
friends so it was a very natural
inclusion into the family so we became
like a trio and that's really when the
writing became truly what the show was
when we were all there together there
was as we say the yin and the yang there
was a man and a woman and we were
equally partners and
coolly creative and it was just I've
never laughed so much for so long
wow that's funny for this series such as
a dark sense of humor but is certainly
not a laugh riot I would say I find it
very funny it's it's funny but it's also
dark as your material is known to be its
art funny yes that's very campy it is
that you're correct yeah
I'm excited to see more some of the dark
humor and it really does hit hit my
particular sense of humor when you guys
are writing together in a trio and I
believe you also worked with two other
writers on the neon demon how do you
like to write as a part of a group do
you sit in a room and work together do
you bounce back versions of this script
take it from here and then someone else
takes it from there well it kind of
depends sometimes I would write the
story or two clear narrative
kind of concept sometimes I have an idea
then I work with someone else to kind of
figure out what it could become
sometimes it do it alone
and just sit in a room and do everything
myself regarding to neon demon I wanted
to work with I wanted to have as many
women around me as possible so of course
the writing process was part of that and
I was very intrigued by how we could
clash and something interesting would
come out of it and also put you out of
your comfort zone when you're challenged
yeah you know we had a great female TP
and on and then the end human a great
female cast it was like that was the
goal was to unlock the
seventeen-year-old girl within me and
everyone has them and so the tools die
young he was became at one point also
very mechanical because we had to
produce so much stuff sure so we were
writing before I started shooting but we
were also writing when I was shooting
because I would keep on changing and in
the end it really just became me sitting
across them here and then basically
dictating what were we had to do and
what we had to
kind of where the story was going in my
mind and then we would come up with
ideas together or scenes together or we
would rewrite scripts that hadn't been
produced yet or sometimes I would go in
and I would change the whole script of
an episode we were actually shooting so
suddenly at you know 10:00 p.m. we were
working until 2:00 a.m. and I had to get
up at 6:00 a.m. to go shooting and I
would still keep on changing it on set
so yeah that creative high is really
what you've become a junkie too but then
you also have to get very
matter-of-factly where you would say I
work with this with that I'll work with
that would Holly product we've got to
cut this this and this and it's done and
then you move on and move on but the
trio functioned because we were a trio
is that room for evolution part of why
you like shooting chronologically so
that you can change the story as you go
yes I believe for me I always say the
product is what's called dead space it's
the process where you're alive
it's the process the act of creativity
is more important than the product
the act of because that's that's we live
the product when it's produced is just
sitting there you know whatever you end
up doing if you're a musician or a
painter or poet or writer filmmaker or
whatever clay installation art
installation it the product isn't is an
extension of you at least in my case but
the process of making is when you're
alive and I don't like knowing I like to
be to to have the ability to be based
all my decision on how do I feel so how
does that how does that translate to the
way you work with actors I mean that's
that's probably a interesting creative
challenge for them as well to have to
not necessarily improv but evolve in
that way as it goes you're gonna have to
ask them but I mean everyone that I work
with and I've been very fortunate to
work with some magnificent actors and
actresses they all seem to really
indulge them set
in the process because from a
performance point of view you no longer
having to mechanically create everything
you can just go with the flow it's also
scary because now there's no right or
wrong you know you it's it's also a form
of dedication because you can't really
be thinking about other things while
you're seeing your lines because it will
be revealed if you're not 100% focused
yeah well you've got a very intense
leading actor here as you often do and
I'm curious how did miles teller become
the guy for this was it was he who you
had in mind did you read a lot of people
for it and he was the best what was the
journey to getting there well the miles
teller character Martin who kind of
Vista star of the show I never got as
far as reading anyone because very early
on I I met with Miles I think it was the
first act that I actually really met
with about the part and face-to-face and
I remember even calling Elle Fanning
going what do you think who do you who
do you think I should cast you know and
getting her take on it and then she was
like you know Mosteller and so I met
with Miles and we had a great
interesting conversation and Miles has a
very funny way of explaining it you know
about how we just stared at each other
for a very long time speaking very very
slowly but in my mind I was just
thinking I can't believe I'm looking at
Elvis Presley and if I can make this
beast of a project
starring Elvis Presley the actual
reincarnation because he looks so much
like yeah and my wife said he walks like
john travolta from you know Saturday
Night Fever and he stands like John
Wayne I was like the iconography of that
because miles is one of the best actors
around so it wasn't a craftsmanship that
you're even debating you it's more like
a sensibility it's the last 10% of to
you and I have something in common
that's going to make this interesting
and I was just right away and I asked
you if you would want it to do it and he
said sure and that was that there was no
reluctance about a 10 month commitment I
think for him it was more even an
excitement because you know an
independent films you get so little time
to do anything so at least here we had
more time yeah that's more of a theater
actor sort of yeah it's like on stage
yeah you get to I mean that's a long
time to spend with a character I so it
was obviously a huge deal that you got
to premiere this at can being the status
of streaming there and everything and
you when you were there your press
conference spoke pretty vocally about
your support of streaming and your
belief in it and then curious why is it
why is it so something that you're so
passionate about and something that was
the necessary sort of medium for this
project well first of all you can say
the you cannot make a 13 hour movie in
the normal theatrical world when you
look at the origin of film in a way this
of sense of a deja vu because back then
you had two great inventors of film
we're making eight hour movies six hour
a movies day because it was a it was an
undiscovered canvas there was no rules
in the game and he would play at five
thousand seat stadium for people to go
and watch his invention called felt and
became mass media and to me streaming is
kind of the equivalent of that because
streaming is part of the digital
revolution where there's a flow around
us that we tap in and out of you know
what's going away is traditional
television
I mean that's that as an art doornail to
me at least and also certainly my
children they were
television why should day I know so our
viewing habits our communication habits
the way that we vote the way that we
interact with each other the way that we
live our lives has changed so much with
streaming and to digital revolution so I
thought when when when I was approached
about doing this or when Amazon came to
me and asking what I wanted to do after
knee and demon I was like I want to do a
really long movie and you can do that in
streaming so that opportunity is just
really interesting because it's where my
kids exist you know I have my eldest is
16 this is her world this is her
language this is her canvas and rather
than trying to bring her world into what
I used to know I want to go into what
they do what how they communicate how
they interact what they see because
they're so smart they're so clever
they're so they're so quick to say I
don't feel it and I think that's
beautiful because it goes back to the
point that creativity is about sincerity
it's about a point of view it's about
inspiration you know we live in a world
that's so obsessed with good or bad or
you know being comfortable that we
forget that arts purpose is to challenge
our comfortability to make us think to
change the world and I think because of
the revolution that has become one more
clear because you know there's no point
in producing content if it doesn't
become something of a catharsis for you
because from an audience including
myself time is precious and if I'm to
give my time away to something what do I
get in return an entertainment God it's
all for free online my telephone gives
me free entertainment yeah so I need to
be I need to be thrilled I need to be
seduced
so the idea that art has reverted back
to this point of view it's far more of a
higher commodity it's much more
important and streaming allows that
because it's a flow of energy we just
tap into and tap out up wherever we are
just like what I make is designed for
the telephone or for the Lumiere
cinnamon can't there's no they can't be
one or the other it has to work on all
different avenues that's a very
interesting perspective because you know
there's a lot of debate about theatrical
versus streaming and what the film
experience is meant to be and I think
you've tapped into something really
powerful and cool that I love about
streaming which is the the intimacy and
immediacy of it and bringing your art
into someone's home instead of asking
them to go to you I think that's a
powerful move especially for an
ambitious project like this that asks an
audience to really pay attention oh
absolutely
and I mean I still love the cinema I
mean I love going to the cinema we had a
fantastic premiere at the Vista yet it
was very romantic it was a beautiful
design
you know Cathedral of dreams and we
projected in that and that was also a
perfect way but it's also equally as
perfect as watching on your iPhone with
your headset somewhere in the forest you
know the the exposure or the creativity
itself should not be determined on how
you view it it can it can it can be pros
and cons it's about you and the
interaction and how you want to be
interacted and if you want to go to the
cinema to see things I love it I love
the cinema but the reality is is that
streaming is the final finale of
everything we do yeah so you also have
to look at that with all the
opportunities that provide you I'm not
saying one is better the others that's
an individual thing it's like who do you
want to have sex with I don't know
whatever makes you happy
lots of good options just whatever makes
you happy yeah I mean and
you're absolutely right everything's
gonna end up - on streaming in the end
anyway
so that is a very wise tactic I'm
curious your thoughts on because you
refer to this as a thirteen hour film
that is the sort of idea of a TV series
versus a long film is something that TV
critics definitely have a lot of very
intense debates about so I'm wondering
what your definition is that makes it a
film is it is it simply structural
things like no commercial break stuff
like that or what what does that mean to
you when you say thirteen hour film well
I decided to make a [ __ ] effin movie
just really really long so that's me
it's a long movie
yeah and of course I didn't use the
systematic three-act structure episodic
storytelling that dominates the general
market because that's what people know
so you make what you know you react to
what you know I don't have an interest
at because I don't watch it I don't to
me it's like it's like an it's like it
suffers in a way the same way that a lot
of cinema suffers is that it's
predictable it's it's pre manufactured
it's pre sought out so many so many
twists you can throw in the same
constructions if you if you wash away
all that all you really have is just
emotions and you have an like a liquid
it's like a flow of emotions it just
comes out and I decided to take all the
tricks of the trade away of what
serialized conventional television and
say I don't have an interest in that I'm
just gonna use the platform to just
expand everything I do into thirteen
hours so now it's the future and that to
me is far more interesting yeah I
watched an interview with you where you
said you are from the future do you feel
that you are catching up with yourself
with the show in that context like
you're finally seeing your your
opportunities match where your brain was
at yes and now I can rethink what the
next future will be like yeah even more
intriguing you have any theories
yes will you share them soon okay fair
enough very coy could I come in peace
that's good thank goodness we need a
little peace if you said that this is
sort of a you just wanted to make a
longer Nicholas wedding Ruffin film what
did you learn about the like yourself as
a filmmaker the way you want to tell
stories in the process of doing that did
you discover new elements that you
hadn't necessarily seen in the shorter
format or new avenues you want to pursue
in the future I'm not I'm not an analyst
like that you know just like I'm not a
politician I'm not here to I'm not
asking for your vote
I can only create what I create the way
I want to do it that's what I can offer
and and and so from that perspective I
don't I don't think about it
so you didn't yeah it's we got a little
visitor here but if you you didn't find
that in having time to tell your story
in a different way that you found you
liked telling it a certain way it just
it felt the same just the same thing
that's so cool I didn't expect that I
always have to look in the world of
creativity as you do and conform to it
it conforms to you so like if you were I
guess I'm perceiving what you mean all
my life I've been told what I should do
and how to do it yeah you know and you
know polarization is the true definition
of success I mean maybe not financial
success but not everything is based on
money yeah you know we we unfortunately
spend a lot of time valuing creativity
at the moment on dollar signs thinking
dollar signs equals quality that's not
it's like the same does that mean that
the most successful restaurant chains
are the best food we all know that's not
so why do we comply that entertainment
the same way of course the business of
entertainment you need to know to exist
but there are dollar and cents of ways
to do things that actually make things
that are the most specifically unique
niche material to be financially upside
but the ideal polarization is that it's
when you have something to argue about
it's what creates the dialogue if you
like something and someone else hates it
then you and that person have an
interaction and art is is our heart it's
our emotions it's how we communicate art
art expands our horizon art moves human
beings forward you know art is the only
element of the human mind that the AI
cannot create they can duplicate it but
it can't create it you can do everything
else we can do with our hands with our
analysts and so forth but it cannot
create because it doesn't have a soul
and soul is a foundation of a point of
view it's the flow of your emotions this
is what I see this is how I feel so all
my life I've always been told especially
by the quote unquote
establishment you know the enemy of
creativity good taste of all the things
I'm doing wrong and it's the same thing
they say and sometimes I always wonder
today I actually think that one day I'm
gonna listen or is it more like maybe
they're just wrong and I'm right
because my mother always said I was a
genius so that's what I'm working out of
and if people don't agree with that
that's fine yeah I don't that's cool and
but it's not gonna change the fact that
it's 100% me and that's what I can offer
you that's the only thing I can
entertain you with I am in the in a day
or showman I am an entertainer but I can
only retain you with what
I am mm-hmm I love it I think that you
are very successful in your mission
because many of the better conversations
or debates I have about movies tend to
be about your film specifically the neon
demon which I freaking love and has as
you're well aware some strong reactions
thank you so that's that's definitely
you are good at creating conversations
and films that that strike people in a
strong way when you come off of making
your 13 hour film
working in streaming working with Amazon
does it make you hungry to do more in
that Avenue are you now like I got I
gotta go make a five week film where's
your head at well I want to make a movie
next just to do something different but
I have hundreds of ideas floating around
that I would like to just you know go
into yeah but everything I do I've kind
of been able to now focus on which is
you know my own streaming site by NWR
that has become now the kind of the
mountain of of my intentions that
everything I now create is to build out
of that whatever it is I'm not sure yet
but that is the next future for me
gotcha it's a very that second is a
really cool layout it's an impressive
design and it's also I mean you aren't
like you've been embracing streaming for
a minute now it's not just this show do
you do you have cuz you are one of those
filmmakers as many are who when you go
look at the news stories there are many
projects over the years that you have
been attached to detached still might be
happening I was happy to hear maniac cop
is still a possibility
do you have ones that are like didn't
happen but keep you up at night still or
do you tend to move on to new ideas when
they don't follow through well I've
never had anything fall through
regarding meeting a cop it's an IP I own
so that will always be when it's ready
the right way it'll be get made I just
don't want to get made to make it that's
not worth people's time or the people
making it it needs to be there for a
reason it was to be made with the
passion but since I owe the IP it's just
it's just standing on a on a hanger in a
beautiful plane just getting ready to
take off it's full of gasoline and now I
just need two last pieces to make sure
that it's the right takeoff regarding
everything else no I mean projects that
I've come to me or that I've been
approached about I've always decided not
to do them in the end you know I I I
love Hollywood I love glamour I love
glitz I love camp I love vanity I love
egos I indulge in all that but the the
bigger kind of approaches are the offers
that has come my way or the interest in
the end I've always just felt that I
wasn't the right person in the end for
it doesn't mean that it won't happen I
mean I I would love to do one of those
comic book I mean yeah yeah I mean me
and Batgirl it's like we coexist yeah
that's right you found your inner
teenage girl so you know you know it's
just let a lot of people obsessed with
this idea if this is it this is I said
if it comes and it's the right and I can
do my version of it or I can be part of
it contribution to that great but if
it's not I'll just go make something
else yeah that makes sense I certainly
everything you've just said about what
you value in art I could see how those
conversations would be difficult I'm
hoping that since Warner Brothers is
leaning a little weird with their comic
books that maybe Batgirl maybe we'll see
that one day I was gonna play in oh
really
I'm sure you wouldn't tell me but maybe
off-camera I have to let you go it's
been so much fun talking with you thank
you for coming in and
Asians on your series and/or 13-hour
film thank you very much